[Music]
over the the past two days we've heard a
lot about data science and machine
learning and analytical workloads I'm
gonna flip the script here and close out
with the talk about large-scale
transactional workloads and the systems
that make them possible I I saw Frank
Marie's talk earlier today about
materialized and he had a little red
square at the time kind of at the bottom
of the screen there were supposed to be
the our TMS our DBMS of the of his
system that's what we're gonna focus on
here so that little red square can I get
a show of hands for people who have used
transactional database in the past
awesome okay so kind of everyone here
how many people have used a distributed
transactional database in the past still
a lot of people that's awesome so today
I'm gonna take you on a whirlwind tour
of the architecture of one such
distributed OLTP database cockroach TV
and my goal is for people to leave here
today with a deeper understanding of the
inner workings of these distributed
sequel databases so here's the three
word pitch for cockroach IV it's make
data easy and this is actually the
mission statement at cockroach labs the
company behind cockroach TB our thesis
is that too much burden has been placed
on app developers traditional sequel
databases have failed to scale
horizontally or survive failures or be
able to replicate kind of across the
world in in in today's application
landscape these are kind of requirements
for developers now no sequel came around
and offered horizontal scalability but
it gave up transactions and indexes and
in some cases even correctness which in
turn put the burden right back on app
developers so there's been an emergence
of this new class of new sequel
databases that promise to bridge this
gap they offer scalability without
giving up on consistency
for diving in though first I'd like to
introduce myself I'm Nathan Ben Ben
Schoen I'm an engineer at cockroach DB
I've been working on it for about four
years first as an open source
contributor and later as an employee of
the company so here's our agenda for the
talk we're gonna start at the bottom of
cockroach TVs architecture and work our
way up so at the very bottom of
cockroach TB is a distributed replicated
transactional key value store that's a
lot of buzzwords but we're gonna go
through each one the first thing to
realize here about this key value store
is that it holds keys and values and
these are arbitrary byte strings but
later we're talk we'll talk about the
structure that higher levels in the
system and Poe is upon these keys and
values so cockroach TV uses
multi-version concurrency control and it
uses a hybrid logical clock scheme to
version these keys and values so that
means that values are never overwritten
they're instead written with a new
version which improves concurrency
within the system and a lot of databases
nowadays use this approach the key value
store exposes a single monolithic
logical key space and this key space is
ordered based off of key here I'm
showing just the keys for clarity but in
reality they're values associated with
each key and in fact multiple versions
of the value associated with each key so
the ordered monolithic will key space is
logical but it's physically realized by
breaking up the key space into 64
megabyte chunks which we call ranges
these ranges start empty they grow as
data is added they split when they get
too large and they merge back together
with their neighbors when they get too
small so conceptually you can think of
cockroach should be is starting with a
single empty range and just growing as
users add data
data is placed into these ranges using
order preserving data distribution we
don't use a hashing scheme like
consistent hashing and this is actually
very important for layering sequel on
top of this key value store the sequel
demands a lot of efficient key value
scans that are ordered within a range
the keys are still ordered on each
physical machine using a per node
embedded key value store and Kakashi B
uses rocks DB for this this purpose so
in order to maintain the ordering
between ranges a range indexing
structure is needed we store the
structure inside a set of well-known
ranges within the system so that anyone
can locate the top of the structure
which ends up looking kind of like a bee
tree this provides a two-level indexing
structure it's similar to BigTable HBase
and spanner so the fully ordered keys
enable efficient scans of ranges here's
a depiction of scanning between a dog's
table between the names muddy and Stella
and you can see that we're using an
indexing structure to look up exactly
what ranges store that span of keys and
then scanning just that over those keys
so now that we've talked about how data
is organized within this key value store
we can now talk about how reads and
writes access the data to do this we're
going to need to switch gears and start
talk about replication for those
unfamiliar replication means keeping
multiple copies of the same piece of
data in sync across machines cartridge
GB uses raft for replication raft is a
distributed consensus protocol that's
similar to paxos now how does concrete
reuse raft well each range within the
system is its own raft group and I'll
say that one more time is its
source of confusion every single range
within cockroach TV runs its own draft
consensus protocol to keep its portion
of the key space in sync across multiple
replicas we don't replicate at the level
of nodes we actually replicate at the
level of these ranges and by replicating
at the level ranges we're able to get
fine-grained control over data placement
across the cluster the distributed
consensus algorithm provides a very
useful building block for our key value
store not being atomic replication
commands which change say are proposed
by a leader distributed to followers and
only accepted when a quorum of these
replicas acknowledge the request so in
raft a quorum means a strict majority
here we see that we have three replicas
holding the same pieces of data when a
write comes in it's distributed to all
three replicas and only once two out of
the three replicas have written the
command to disk is it acknowledged to
the client and this means that even if
some of the nodes here fail the write
will still be present in the system so
this is an important part of cockroach
TVs resiliency story as it means that we
can lose machines and still stay online
so quorum replication is reasonable for
rights but it's actually fairly
expensive for reads where no state is
changing consider this example of
reading a key from our dog's table using
a consensus read would mean we would
have to go to all three replicas wait
for a majority or to respond and piece
together the response to the determine
what was the consistent state across
them the replicas this would slow down
the reads and impose extra network
traffic throughout the cluster it would
be pretty nice if we could just go to a
single replica ask for its local state
and return that to the client
but we can't just read from any replica
because that repla might be behind it
might not have the latest State forgiven
key yet the the replica that coordinates
these rights which I've called the
leader so far but we're actually gonna
call the leaseholder from this point on
is always a way of what rights have been
committed so it can service reads
without communicating with other
replicas in the system so we say that
the lease holder has the ranges lease
and these leases give cockroach to be
consistent reads without consensus in an
edition the lease holder implements some
of the concurrency control mechanisms
used by transactions which we'll talk
about later
these include key range locking and
deadlock detection so I said the data
and cockroach TB is stored in ranges and
these ranges are replicated and that can
be stored across any nodes in the
cluster so where do we put the replicas
well this is the replica placement
problem and there are four signals that
cockroach EB uses to determine where to
place replicas in the interest of time
I'm going to skip over the first
heuristic here these it can be summed up
as we try to balance space utilization
across the cluster we don't want any one
node running out of space so let's serve
with diversity base placement for a
distributed system diversity improves
availability when replicas are spread
across failure domains failure domains
are any unit of failure such as a disk a
single machine a rack a data center or
even a region for obvious reasons we
wouldn't want to store the same piece of
data on the same disk because if that
disk went down we'd lose both copies so
cockroach TB attempts to spread replicas
across as many failure domains as
possible while adhering to admin
preferences for where that data can and
can't be
now the next heuristic is replica for
replica placement is load you might
imagine that spreading out the space
usage across the cluster would be enough
to spread out load but that's not really
the case for instance I said earlier
that the reads are only serviced by
lease holders so if we put all the lease
holders on the same node then all of the
reads would be going to that one node
then we'd have a huge imbalance in CPU
utilization and network traffic so the
first mechanism here is to spread out
lease holders across the cluster
unfortunately load isn't evenly
distributed across the key space either
for instance in this slide range that
the blue range here has a lot higher
load than the rest of the key space and
we see this in practice all over the
place customers often have reference
tables that are accessed on every single
query and those tables end up being a
lot hotter than the rest of the system
so Congress GB tracks per range load
metrics and then balances load for those
ranges across the cluster in this case
we see that the blue range ends up on
its own nodes because its axis so
frequently and in practice there are
thousands of ranges per node but this
heuristics still very important in the
final heuristic that is used to
determine where to place replicas is
latency so the distributed key-value
store is actually a geo distributed
key-value store and the geo part is very
important here these geographical
agencies can be very significant from
tens of milliseconds for small hops to
hundreds of milliseconds for large hops
so cockroach DB implements two
mechanisms to place data where it's
needed the first is a manual mechanism
where a user can specify for instance
that all the replicas for range must
reside in one locality or they can
specify that the leaseholders for one
range must be in some locality for
instance they might specify that the
leaseholders for all ranges containing
users data must remain in California
because its first being accessed the
other mechanism is automatic cockroach
TV attempts to move lease holders and
replicas close to where they're being
accessed from so this is called follow
the workload and allows cockroach to
automatically move data to where it's
being accessed and adapt to changes in
workloads so moving up the stack the
next thing we'll talk about is
transactions is this a I said this was a
transactional key value store cockroach
implements serializable isolation and
the topic of isolation levels are
confusing but fascinating it's a very
deep topic and yet serializable
isolation is kind of easy to think about
it's fairly intuitive concurrent
transactions behave as if they were
executed in some serial order and
there's no interleaving of operations
between them so again this goes back to
making data easy these transactions
cockroach can span arbitrary ranges of
keys they can touch the entire key space
if they want to and they can be accessed
using a conversational interface this
conversational interface is important
for sequel these applications often will
start a transaction read some data
manipulate it in their application and
write it back all within the same
transaction so let's dive into the
implementation of transactions briefly
transactions provide a unit of a thermos
City they're all or nothing they either
succeed or they fail altogether
in transaction level a de minimis city
in cockroach TV is bootstrapped on top
of range level atom isset e provided by
raft each transaction has an Associated
transaction record an update to the
transaction record are stored on a
single range so we're able to in direct
through this transaction record to
provide ad Amissah T for the entire
transaction
I'll walk through a simple example and
here we have an insert statement that's
inserting two rows into a sequel table
which is backed by a four node cluster
the insert statement is inserting two
dogs into our dogs table and the sequel
execution layer will turn this into a
series of key value operations in this
case we're writing the keys Sonny and
Ozzy and inside of a single transaction
the first thing that a transaction does
when it begins life is it creates its
transaction record and it will store
this on the first range that the
transaction writes to the transaction
record really only has one piece of
information just the status of the
transaction here it begins its life as a
pending transaction and later it will
move into either a committed status or a
final or an aborted status so each write
the transaction performs while it's
running is called a provisional intent
the intents are tagged with the
transactions ID and if another
transaction encounter is one of these
intents it has to hop over to the
transaction record to determine whether
that intent should be visible or not
so we see that both the transaction
record and the intent on Sonny are
replicated amongst this first range here
and because we're using raft would wait
for a majority of replicas to
acknowledge the change before continuing
on the sequel layer then moves on to
writing the second key which might be on
different range than the first key so it
goes to the leaseholder for this second
range the the range in blue and inserts
an intent on Ozzy and again the
leaseholder proposes this to its
followers and followers acknowledge
finally the sequel gateway which is the
the node processing the sequel commits
the transaction which involves
going back to the transactions record
and marking as committed this operation
is again replicated for durability and
when that's complete the transaction is
considered committed so the sequel kqa
can go back to the client and say your
transaction is complete can acknowledge
the client and finally the background
process cleans up intense so that reads
of them don't need to go visit a
transaction record but note that even if
it didn't succeed in time if it didn't
clean up these intents in time reads of
these intents would go to the
transaction record find that the
transaction is committed and treat the
intent as if it was committed so I've
talked a lot about keys and values but
concrete GB is a G distributed sequel
database so now it's time to talk about
sequel cockroach implements the sequel
that you're familiar with kind of
standard sequel from schemas to indexes
to transactions to foreign keys the
dialect of sequel that we implement is
actually exactly post-crisis and the
wire protocol that we speak is exactly
post-crisis so your client application
thinks it's talking to a Postgres
database when it's talking to cockroach
gb the goal here is for users to be able
to pick up active record or hibernate or
whatever tools they're used to using and
plug them right in without missing a
beat so I'm sure most people here are
familiar with sequel sequels declarative
in that you describe the results you
want and not the steps for how to return
those results and this is important as
it provides a tremendous amount of
flexibility within the implementation of
sequel but that is also a large burden
for the sequel database implementers
sequel is tabular and tables are
composed of rows and columns the columns
are to find in a schema and these
columns have types like float or string
tables have optional indexes that
provide efficient look up into the
and they have foreign keys to enforce
referential integrity but wait a minute
I said sequel data has columns and types
and yet we've talked only about untyped
key value pairs this seems rather
distant but it turns out it's it's not
too distant we can map sequel directly
onto key value pairs without all that
much work and we'll see how let's start
with a basic table here in cockroach and
in most sequel databases every table has
a primary key which is just a special
index this required to be unique and
required to store all of the columns in
the table each row in the primary key
maps directly to a single key value pair
and each row in a secondary index also
masks just to a single key value pair
for each index the index columns are
encoded into the key of the kV pair and
the non index columns are encoded into
the value of the KB pair we can see this
here you can probably imagine a scheme
for encoding the value here we could
have used protobufs or Avro or any other
encoding scheme in practice we chose to
do our own encoding for performance but
it doesn't really matter
what matters much more though is the
encoding of the keys we need an encoding
such that the encoded key is ordered the
same way the logical columns they encode
are so with our inventory table here we
need the encoded ID column to be encoded
with the same ordering as what we
logically consider integers so people
here might be able to come up with an
encoding that would work for that
requirement and I'm just going to gloss
over the fact that it actually is
possible to do that this with arbitrary
tuples so we can do this with arbitrary
data types and arbitrary tuples we
didn't invent this idea but we use it
heavily during this mapping from sequel
to key value stores to key values
so cockroach supports multiple tables
and indexes by just prefixing each key
with the table and the index name so
this what it looks like for an inventory
table here but sequel's a lot more than
just table data storage it equals a
powerful query language and since
cockroach is a sequel database we need
to implement that query language I'm
going to go through a quick overview of
how basic sequel query execution works
before diving into distributed query
execution and finishing up with the
mention on query optimization so sequel
has a relatively small number of basic
relational operations as projection
selection aggregation and joining in
just a few more these are expressed in
sequel via constructs like select where
group by and join these relational
operators are part of relational
expressions in a query tree or query
plan for a sequel query is just a tree
of these relational expressions pieced
together in executing a query plan just
runs this runs these operations to
completion so I'll give a brief example
of how sequel query execution works with
this statement here here we you see
we're reading from an inventory table
and filtering on the name column so what
this looks like under the hood is that
we start with the scan we start with the
source of the the data and we pass this
through a filter operator so we're
filtering based off of the name of each
row the resulting filtered rows are
projected out to just show the columns
that are desired here in this case just
the name column and that result is
returned to the client
so it's all actually fairly
straightforward but here it's actually
fairly inefficient as well people might
have picked up on the fact that we're
performing a full table scan here we're
scanning over the entire inventory table
before we're actually filtering at all
and without more information that's
really all we can do but what if we had
an index directly on this name column
well if we had an index on the name
column we could scan a continuous set of
keys and perform the filtering right
there in the scan we could push the
filter into the scan itself we'd still
have to reject out the name column but
this is a fast operation and then we
would just return the results of the
clients so the decision to use such an
index is called a transformation and
it's performed that by the sequel
optimizer I'll dive into that shortly at
high level these relational operators
are straightforward but there are still
two fairly large challenges we have to
deal with the first here is correctness
user-defined schemas mean that there's a
lot of generality involved in sequel and
that results in a lot of bookkeeping and
making that bookkeeping fastest is
tricky and that leads into the second
the second challenge here we need to
make this fast users expect sequel
execution to be performing now there are
three tactics that we use to make sequel
performant
the first is fairly straightforward we
try to write write tight well-written
code that doesn't allocate during
individual rows and it doesn't waste a
lot of CPU the next tactic is something
that most sequel systems will do where
we specialized operators to specific
scenarios for instance a general purpose
group by operator needs to handle inputs
that are unordered and it typically does
this using a hash table but if the input
is ordered then often we can skip the
hash table and
and just stream the results back up
lastly being a distributed system means
that we can distribute sequel execution
entirely so I'm we're a little short on
time so I'm gonna skip straight to this
last point with the geo distributed
database network latency and throughput
become very important considerations and
with a distributed sequel execution
we're able to push fragments of
computation as close to the data as
possible to avoid these slowing down
queries let's look at an example of a
sequel query that's aggregating rows
using a group by operator if the table
is distributed across three data centers
then the query will instantiate three
processors to scan the table these
processors sit right next to the data
that they're scanning and the output is
fed right into a local group by operator
it's still right in the same data center
finally the per data center group by
operator output is fed back to a single
final stage and that's what's returned
to the client so this reduces network
usage over these wide area network links
and also offers an opportunity for
parallelism which is beneficial even
when you're running a system like
cockroach within a single data center so
moving on to our last topic and I think
we are short on time yeah so I said the
sequel queries are declarative and that
it's up to the single database to decide
how to execute them and this ends up
being the job of the sequel optimizer so
there can be a lot of logically
equivalent plans and it's up to the
optimizer to choose which one to run now
there are there are four stages here to
running a query we start by just parsing
the query and turning it into an
abstract syntax tree next we prepare the
query by folding constants and checking
types and doing a lot
preparation work finally we use a
cost-based our cost-based optimizer to
search through the different
transformations that can be possible on
this query to decide if there are any
better query plans that could be made
and then we pick the lowest cost query
to run so that was an overview but when
it comes to us who want sequel
optimization they're actually two types
of query transformations there are cost
independent transformations and cost
dependent transformations I'll start
with the first one here so cost
independent transformations our
transformations that always make sense
to run on a query and again we're
searching for the best query plan to run
so we always want to run these
transformations an example this is
twofold constants before we actually run
the query we don't want to be doing this
per row so we want to do this ahead of
time now a cockroach these are all
defined in a custom DSL and the DSL
allows us to match against patterns
within a query plan and then perform the
transformation right in line there's
also another set of transformations that
aren't universally good some of them
produce faster query plans and some
don't internally cockroach calls these
exploration rules these they're
exploring the set of logically
equivalent query plans so how do we
decide whether to apply one of these
rules if they're not always good
well we actually always apply them and
then we store both the pre and post
applied version of the query plan so if
you're thinking that that could get
expensive fast then you're right but
this memo structure allows it to be kind
of feasible to do this and then we use
table statistics to estimate the actual
cost of each of these query plans
so here the last example of what this
looks like I'm gonna skip there here we
have a query that's scanning over your
table a filtering based off of a column
X and then ordering based off of
why the question is what query plan do
we choose to execute this query the
initial ast gives us something like this
or we're just gonna scan filter and then
sort and this is pretty basic but this
would work if you have an index on
column X then we can push the filter
into the scan and we saw this earlier
and this would speed up the execution
and if we have an index on Y we can use
the B ordering in the index to avoid
this sort so this again could speed up
execution but it's unclear which of
these last two query plans are better
what really it really matters how many
rows are passing between each stage of
this query plan so for instance if the
for if filtering brought us down to just
10 rows then the scan would be very fast
so we'd want to choose that sorting 10
rows is very quick but if filtering left
us with half of the rows then we
wouldn't really save much by using the
index on X however we would avoid the
entire sort if we use the index on Y so
we'd actually want to choose that one
and we really can't know ahead of time
which one will be better but we can use
table statistics to get an estimate for
what one will be better and then pick
the cheaper plan so something that
cockroach does because it's distributed
that most systems don't have to deal
with is that it actually takes locality
into consideration in its cost model so
just like we were using table statistics
to determine which query to run before
taraji actually uses the locality of the
data that's scanning to determine which
query plan to run here I've defined a
table called postal codes that has an
index on ID its primary key and actually
there's two different indexes has three
different copies of the data in all
three regions
within the world this is a typical
reference table that foreign keys might
be pointing at the optimizer is able to
use the locality of the different
indexes to determine which of these
indexes to run queries against to avoid
wide air and network hops and this is a
simple example but the mechanism is
general and we get a lot of use out of
this so let's review internally
cockroach contains a distributed
replicated transactional key value store
the Cavey store exposes a monolithic key
space that's physically broken down into
64 megabyte chunks replicas within these
chunks can be placed on any node and a
replica placement a set of replicas
placement heuristics determine where to
place these replicas tabular sequel data
is mapped onto this key value store
sequel execution is a lot of bookkeeping
along with a heavy dose of performance
and distributed sequel execution it
moves partial sequel execution as close
to where the data resides as possible
sequel optimization attempts to find the
best execution plan for logical query
and locality aware sequel optimization
recognizes the importance of latency in
determining the best sequel execution
plan and that's really it so at this
point you've kind of all walked through
all the architecture in a distributed
sequel database and you're all certified
to go build a sequel database so
congratulations
I thank you for this deep dive into
database architecture it's great
could you comment on how cockroach to be
fits into big data ecosystem what are
the potential alternatives that you
might be replacing because of the
benefits you offer versus other tools
that may be in the more complementary
for example like analytical databases or
sequel engines right how like things
like I'll presto would interact with
cockroach DB yeah that's a great
question so cockroach DB is definitely
focusing on OLTP use cases and so
there's still a big need for an OLAP
system often to sit alongside one of
these OLTP databases so we work with
tools like snowflake DB to kind of
stream changes from cockroach straight
into analytical databases there there is
work to make kind of white analytics
work within cockroach but it's it's not
designed for that tool yeah how does
cockroach deal with Gateway failure
during a transaction yeah
so typically deployments of cockroach
will have a load balancer out in front
so you'll be balancing sequel to
different nodes in the cluster but if
your gateway fails while you're
executing a transaction that transaction
will be killed and it won't complete but
the the client application will get an
error and we'll just have to retry on a
different gateway so you mentioned a
cockroach collects a memo of the
possible query execution plans and
really like runs through a new iterate
on it and figure out how long it should
take how does that move feed into the
query executor on top of statistics
because based on example you provide it
looks like statistics as more around
number of records in this range and
things like that yeah
so I think I mentioned statistics twice
in this talk
one was about load on arrange but we
also keep kind of per column and per
table tables to the statistics which
work just like a traditional
space optimizer so within the memo we'll
be pruning plans based off of the
expected number of kind of the expected
cardinality to expect through our query
plan I see so you don't actually track
the action but you mentioned that so the
third kind of metrics I track is actual
query execution time yes that feedback
into the statistics right now that
doesn't be back into those statistics
now
[Music]